wir holen konnte engel und ihren
augenstein mit in das gespräch habe
gerade zum eingangs schon gesagt sie
beide sind auch gegen die impfpflicht
erleben sie das im freundes und
bekanntenkreis bei der arbeit also im
beruflichen umfeld auch dass man sich so
oft über dieses thema im pflicht dass
man sich voneinander ab kehrt dass man
einander nicht mehr zuhört
ladies first oder weil die anfragen
ja ja ja ist ja das erleben wir im
privaten umfeld und auch auf arbeit
natürlich leben wir das täglich dass
diskussionen aufkommen und die meinungen
weit auseinander gehen im familienkreis
wirklich die familie sich ver streitet
also es ist ganz vor sport zu sehen und
im
dienstlichen umfeld es ist natürlich für
uns er pfiff und pflegedienst ja schon
einschneidend wie sich das jetzt
entwickelt hat wir sind ähnlich würdige
dienst und legen dienste darauf kommen
wir noch mal ganz kurz wollte einmal den
familien und den freundeskreisen ganz
bleiben herr augenstein kennen sie das
teilen sie diese erfahrung irgendwann
hört man dann auf miteinander zu
sprechen zu streiten weil eine
diskussion offenbar nicht mehr richtig
möglich ist naja ich denke man darf nie
aufhören zu diskutieren und muss man
muss das thema ernst genug nehmen und
man muss vor allem mit argumenten
dagegen gehen man für mich war die
impfungen immer eine beruhigung und ich
habe auch mittlerweile die dritte die
booster impfung für mich ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit ich habe mich
impfen lassen aber es gibt im verwandten
und bekanntenkreis sehr viele die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen bis jetzt und
darüber geht es aber jetzt nicht zu
sagen nein mit denen rede ich nicht mehr
sondern genau deswegen muss ich mit
denen reden und weiterhin in kontakt
bleiben und mit argumenten mit
sachlichen argumenten nicht stark verbal
auseinandersetzen sondern man muss sich
nach wie vor in die augen schauen können
das ist ganz wichtig in der demokratie
muss das weiterhin gelebt und erlebt
werden und deswegen muss es auch
politisch wege geben hier auch von der
information her weiter nicht weiter zu
deeskalieren und es ist ganz wichtig um
weitere schritte setzen zu können für
die gesellschaft im gesamten ich erlebte
es auch wieder ich bin bei der dlrg auch
ihren vorteilen der teststation immer
beim arbeiten und wir haben hier
wirklich diskussion darüber wenn man
erst mal ein bisschen zeitfenster hat
durchaus natürlich welche die sich nicht
ihn verlassen möchten aber man darf das
man man muss mit den leuten in die
diskussion gehen und man muss es auch
mal akzeptieren diese gründe die sie
anbringen das kann vielfältig sein aber
man darf nicht sagen mit ihr möchte ich
nichts mehr zu tun haben und du bist für
mich weg vom fenster in hollersbach auch
leute die sind auch in dieser sendung
frau engel warum jetzt hat gerade herr
augenstein schon gesagt er hat sich
impfen lassen erleben die impfpflicht
trotzdem ab er schläge sagt das auch für
sich in dresden sie haben ihre
entscheidung anders getroffen sie haben
sich bisher nicht haben impfen lassen
was waren für sie die wichtigsten gründe
die wichtigsten gründe für mich waren
anfangs erst mal dass abzuwarten dann
für war für mich dieser dieser druck der
immer mehr aufgebaut wurde brachte mich
eigentlich zum nachdenken warum wird es
gemacht und
dann die auftretenden nebenwirkungen die
aber nicht
veröffentlicht werden also nicht in den
öffentlich rechtlichen medien
veröffentlicht werden es sorgt keiner
bei der werbung für die impfungen dazu
dass eine thrombose auftreten kann das
ein harter brocken große auftreten kann
dass vermehrt
herzmuskelentzündungen zur folge haben
kann das sagt mir keiner dazu und das
macht mich skeptisch und je mehr der
druck aufgebaut wird umso mehr
erschließt sich mir eigentlich die
bereitschaft zur
impfung das ist der eindruck von frau
engel über die nebenwirkungen natürlich
auch immer wieder berichtet worden ganz
genauso natürlich darüber dass die
impfung grundsätzlich von der schweren
erkrankung deutlich besser schützt als
die nicht im keller aber sie haben
bisher frau inge sie und alle ihre
kollegen und kolleginnen nicht
überzeugen können von impfung trotz
werbekampagnen ganz viel kohle die das
gesundheitsministerium da reingesteckt
haben jetzt hören wir von der
lauterbacher will noch mal drauf sagte
laut der zielgeraden nochmal ne fette
werbekampagne startet alles nicht
angekommen alles hat nicht funktioniert
in jeder pressekonferenz wo sie da vorne
saßen mit herrn söder und frau merkel
damals noch haben sie auch geworben
haben aufgerufen uns ins gewissen
geredet nichts angekommen bei frau engel
warum das muss sie beantworten also ich
glaube erst mal dass es richtig ist
weiter zu werben wir haben ja 75 prozent
der menschen auch erreicht die die
impfungen in anspruch genommen haben
also es ja nicht so dass es keine
erfolge gibt und es ist auch immer
wieder dargestellt worden wo
möglicherweise risiken sind wenn wir
alleine an die stieg und denken die
empfehlung abgegeben hat für die eine
oder andere bevölkerungsgruppe weil sie
erst mal informationen brauchte oder
erfahrungen hatte mit risiken also es
ist breit kommuniziert worden
offensichtlich sind die bilder die sie
und andere ja auch senden aus den
krankenhäusern von den intensivstationen
noch nicht intensiv genug dass einige
immer noch glauben dass sie ohne eine
impfung ist schon irgendwie gut
überstehen werden oder aber es werden
und das werden können gerne mit frau
engel direkt sprechen ja sie ist
leiterin eines pflegedienstes also dort
wo es mir unbegreiflich ich muss es
wirklich so sagen wir haben zu beginn
der pandemie haben wir gesehen wie
gerade die ältesten wirklich gestorben
sind ohne dass wir eine chance hatten
sie zu schützen innerhalb kürzester zeit
hat das extrem hohe todesraten gegeben
und wir haben an der stelle wo wir
anfangen konnten zu impfen bei den
ältesten 80 90 70 jährige dann in dieser
reihenfolge
da haben wir gesehen dass sie geschützt
sind und nicht mehr sterben wie man so
etwas in einem pflegeheim jahr mit
beobachten kann und dann sagt aber die
impfung ist nicht mein mittel der wahl
um dieser krankheit zu entgehen tut mir
leid das ist für mich schwer
nachvollziehbar vorgänger der
pflegedienst aber erklären sich sein
müller was ihr grund ist bei uns sind
die
älteren männer die ältere generation
auch mit impfung verstorben also die
impfung hat nicht nicht geschützt
dahingehend aber tut mir leid ich stehe
auch nicht wieso man wieso man jetzt mit
mit dieser impfpflicht dass das
aufzwingen will obwohl wir doch wissen
dass eine dass diese impfung nicht vor
einer infektion schützt richtig und
einem mitarbeiter eine eine
schwester die auch eine intensivstation
arbeitet hat mir selber gesorgt
die wahl zwischen ich verleugne nicht
corona also ich sage nicht dass corinna
nicht gibt aber den virus gibt es auch
schon lange
und die hat mir gesagt die wahl zwischen
corona und der impfung ist die wahl
zwischen pest und cholera das sagen sie
mir dazu
ich hatte corona für mich wurde es ein
mittelschweres wortes ein schnupfen
erkältung und ich würde normalerweise
mit sowas nie zu hause bleiben habe in
der zeit wo ich wohne hat er von zu
hause zehn zwölf stunden gearbeitet weil
ich ja nicht auf ins büro durfte
hat mich persönlich keinerlei
eingeschränkt ich weiß aber dass es
andere verläufe gibt und ich akzeptiere
das natürlich auch dass menschen die
davor angst haben sich mit einer impfung
schützen möchten und das möchte ich aber
doch dass das jeder für sich selber
entscheiden soll nein tut mir leid denn
wenn einmal wir sind es ja ähnlich wir
sind hier an einem punkt wo
faktenbasiert werden und das muss man
wirklich wir haben die bilder die waren
ja nicht gestellt sondern wir haben die
bilder gesehen aus italien wir haben sie
aus deutschland gesehen mit überlasteten
intensivstationen wir haben die zahlen
die sind alle nachzulesen wie viele
menschen 80 90 70 jährige gestorben sind
als wir den impfstoff noch nicht hatten
seit monaten sehen wir diese überlastung
wie wir sie vor anderthalb jahren
gesehen haben auf den intensivstationen
nicht mehr wir sehen das immer noch 80
und 90 jährige versterben aber längst
nicht mehr in dem umfang wie vorher wir
wissen da haben sie recht man kann sich
auch mit einer impfung infizieren wir
wissen aber auch mit der impfung ist der
krankheitsverlauf deutlich einfacher und
deutlich geringer das sind fakten die
man doch mal zur kenntnis nehmen muss
und sie leben nicht alleine auf dieser
welt und sie leben auf dieser welt und
treffen sich mit familie freunden
arbeitskollegen und die impfung die sie
in anspruch nehmen schützt auch all die
menschen mit denen sie sich trifft